danièle cauchard chose
chose je suis rouge dans mon bonheur et
puis je suis noir dans mon malheur qui
suis-je
mon nez rouge dans mon bonnet e mois les
noirs de nos malheurs et oui oui oui
nicolas tucat antipathie grosbill com
une route gauville des globules rouges
et les globules blancs sont là pour
s'occuper du corps à grosbill dans
l'oubli globull globules à c'est la même
chose tu as compris mais je te donne un
indice a atteint de mater gamin le matin
cros matin
pepsi au bout du petit matin au bout du
petit matin grand matin aux médias et
ses choix alors madrid quoi avait à
boire aux propos nous voyez vous le
caféier et puis bourg magnifique solaire
transmis side haroun mir café puis sur
la branche navale son bonheur et puis
vient ce jour en le chauffant pour notre
bonheur à nous ce malheur ils brûlent la
bonne odeur de son malheur du foirail
son malheur fait notre bonheur tu veux
dire qu'à faire et oui c'est oui ou
trois petites choses telles choses comme
mon grand-père les mener la gale
à la tête de mon grand père est pleine
de galles la terre en grand père est
pleine de galles à je trouve c'est un
fruit c'est le corps au sol avec la
galerie le matricule type pareil qu'aux
annonce a pesé sur les prix mais les
gens n'ont pas ça les plus belles que
coureur n'est qu'un pauvre aux aztèques
pastèque la pointe hague a dit donne-moi
lundi si bon chemin
well fruits là est née l'idée en même
temps et l'autre fuir au procès les
avocats se montrant aux avocats je vois
un gros mois je vois je trouvais patil
c'est le jacquet jacques dans les jalles
8 les anomalies jacques j'ai trouvé les
ja
j'aime le jardin légumes avec un bon
petit piment
tout le monde le jeu n'est ce pas tout
le monde aime le jade constitue le
jacques daniel amouny m jacques 1 me out
i jacquard riau ce monde dit ou money
est meilleure qu'à croiser baroin
c'est pas vrai un coup ça ou koné moussa
diao
qu'est ce que disney wonder woman waza
gr 1 qui prétend pas ac l'a dit tout et
tout et tout est vu comme ça à zag la
quitte à vauban manger elle fouille ap
action manioc jana je connais cet état
d'esprit là ça c'est vieux sage
on a scanné ça depuis longtemps c'est un
état d'esprit qui existe depuis nos
ancêtres même les animaux se comporte
comme ça c'est le rejet de soi la honte
de soi on regarde les autres autrement
même les fruits des arbres se comporte
comme ça tiens tu connais pas l'histoire
de la petite banane de la république
bananière du congo tu connais pas à
tanger tétouan raconter tes à vous aussi
il était une fois une petite banane de
la république bananière du combo qui
avait quitté son pays pour aller
continue ses études à face par mail
était fier d'atterrir à paris capitale
du pays des droits de l'homme
waouh et moi de la télé et you petites
bananes de la république bananière du
congo toi comme ma mère m'a demandé de
m'allonger au bout du petit matin du
passage des examens comme le certificat
d'études de porc le brevet des collèges
ou comme le baccalauréat comme la
licence comme la maîtrise et qu'on peut
me conduire en daniel l'état d'esprit je
te dis c'est pour les gens importants
permis de conduire c'est pour les
ouvriers commune dr comme l'agrégation
comme petite banane toi que ma mère me
demandait de manger en me disant comme
ça fils n'oublie pas de manger une
petite banal quand tu vas passer un
examen important
pourquoi maman pourquoi passe de sarah
même délit j'en fais petite balle en de
la république bananière du congo j'ai
besoin de toi viens me rendre
intelligent et la traîtresse de me
répondre comme ça à nier
non maman je ne veux pas je ne suis plus
ta petite banane de la république
bananière du congo je suis maintenant
une pompe de france
enfin quoi pomme de france 3 et quel
genre de ponctuer donc tu fais du tort à
terreni comme sa petite banane ne séduit
pas question prend une banane de la
république bananière du congo ou même
daniel de la réunion qu'elle prenne
l'avion qu'on l'attend un sport de
jusqu'en france
ça change rien cela reste une banane
ne sais tu pas que les français de
france comme des pommes de france non je
m'en fiche je ne suis plus une petite
banane de la république bananière et
congo maintenant je suis et nous parle
de france face voilà daniel comment se
comportent les gens qui ont ôté de même